nearly a year into the war Ukraine is
using more ammunition than NATO
countries can produce tank and artillery
shells are especially needed amid fears
that Ukraine could soon run out NATO
Secretary General announced new
contracts with the arms industry this is
now becoming a grinding War of Attrition
and a war attrition is a war of
logistics and and therefore this is so
crucial for our ability to ensure that
Ukraine winds is able to retake
territory and for this to happen NATO
Nations need to dig deeper into their
pockets The Pledge eight years ago to
spend two percent of the country's
annual budget on defense won't be enough
to face what stoltenberg calls a more
dangerous world today I believe that
just spending two percent will not be
enough it must be the basis for
everything that follows the German
government is debating that right now
and will soon reach an agreement last
year German committed to an additional
100 billion euros to defend spending but
only a fraction has materialized so far
NATO Secretary General has called it a
battle of logistics the race to speed up
production of weapons and ammunition
both within NATO and in Russia only a
year ago many countries didn't see the
need to prioritize defense spending but
the war in Ukraine has changed this the
challenge is now to deliver these
weapons and Munitions in time
Ukraine says they needed to fight off a
new Russian offensive their urgent
requests for F-16 fighter jets has yet
to be answered if they will start a real
offensive campaign certainly they will
use aircrafts from their side trying to
stop our Defense
Forces and they will dominate in the sky
that means it's a real threat that's why
we need more sophisticated more modern
aircrafts to stop them to defeat them to
determine them
NATO members are reluctant to send
fighter jets fearing and escalation of
the war for now they want to focus on
making sure weapons and ammunition
already promised reaches the battlefield
step fast and Al Jazeera Brussels